bonjour messieurs merci beaucoup d'être
en direct ce matin pour parler de
l'antisémitisme faire un point à
l'occasion de ce procès qui s'ouvre
aujourd'hui un gramme survenu le 23 mars
2018 un an après le meurtre à paris de
sarah halimi une sexagénaire juif qui a
été jetée de son balcon ça cela avait
entraîné une marche blanche dans paris
et relancé le débat sur un nouvel
antisémitisme liées à l'islamisation de
de certains quartiers tout d'abord votre
réaction à ce procès des assassins de
demi räikkönen qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui
aux assises de paris alexandre tous ses
chances par vous
et écoutez je pense que c'est
extrêmement important on le doit bien
sûr à la victime on y voit bien sûr à la
famille mais aussi pour peut-être
éclairer la société sur cette nouvel
antisémitisme que dont vous avez parlé
on connaissant en france d'antisémitisme
lié à l'extrême droite à une forme de
catholicisme réactionnaire et c'est vrai
que les c'est pas nouveau on constate un
nouvel antisémitisme en france qui est
plutôt
liée à une montée de l'islamisme
politique liée à une montée de l'extrême
gauche sioniste et il est important
d'éclairer la société sur ce nouvel
antisémitisme et les dégâts que ça peut
produire sur des femmes et là on en
présence d'une femme extrêmement âgées
handicapées on voit bien la barbarie de
ces faits à léon des fontaines même même
question pour vous et votre réaction à
ce procès qui sauverait et dont le
caractère antisémite a été retenu cette
fois
oui bah c'est un procès très important
après un acte ignoble qui a eu lieu en
plein paris et il nous vient nous
rappeler tristement mais oh je pense que
le plus important dans ce procès c'est
bien de se rappeler que l'antisémitisme
est toujours là toujours présent dans
notre société et même au contraire les
actes antisémites augmente dans notre
société de l'importance de pouvoir de
lutter contre toute forme dans six
d'antisémitisme d'où qu'ils viennent et
de toutes formes d'obscurantisme quel
qu'il soit et je pense que c'est
essentiel aussi de pouvoir bah du coup
profité de ce procès pour rappeler à
tous les jeunes à tout le monde que l'on
dise mais toujours là et qu'il se nouent
et de l'obscurantisme et qu'il faut
lutter contre contre ce mal vu dans
l'ignorance la pandémie de coronavirus a
d'ailleurs entraîné une nouvelle vague
d'antisémitisme sur les réseaux sociaux
des dizaines de milliers de messages sur
les raisons sont accusés par exemple
l'élite juive de propager le virus
alexandre touzet cet obscurantisme va
jusque là comment peut-on croire de
telles choses aujourd'hui
et à l'écouter on l'a vu dans les
manifestations contre le passé iter on a
vu des pancartes on a vu des gens les
portes et on a eu des gens à côté de ces
pancartes ne pas prendre la distance
nécessaire
donc effectivement c'est un mal latent
on le sent blanc dans la société à
chaque fois qu'il arrive quelque chose
de complexe
on trouvait des victimes expiatoires ou
des boucs émissaires et effectivement
vous avez tout à fait raison de relever
que cet antisémitisme
il attend et cas chaque situation il
revient
malheureusement dans la société comment
le combattre ça vous voulez on des
fontaines cet antisémitisme qui fait des
jus des boucs émissaires de tous les
maux de la planète j'allais dire comment
le combattre sur les réseaux sociaux
il faut combattre dans l'ensemble de la
société mais aujourd'hui on ne peut que
déplorer je pense l'actualité notamment
de certaines de certains polémiste qui
on visait notamment à réhabiliter
notamment la figure de de pétain qui a
été quand même condamné pour la
banalisation de l'antisémitisme et
surtout pour indignité nationale suite à
la politique discriminatoire est
profondément antisémite qu'il a mené
pendant le régime de vichy je pense
qu'on peut que déplorer que dans un
débat pour une élection présidentielle
nous en arrivons à de telles de telles
paroles et je pense qu'il faut au
contraire renforcer notamment tout qui
juridique qui peut avoir qui a été mise
en place notamment aux années 90 sous
l'impulsion du député communiste gayssot
pour notamment rendre inéligibles les
personnes qui ont été condamnées pour
appels à la haine raciale à
l'antisémitisme et la xénophobie je
pense que ça serait une mesure forte et
ça éviterait aussi quand nous arrivons à
d un débat politique qui est pollué
notamment par des des sorties polémiques
tels que celles qui ont été sortis / / /
pétain et je pense que ça déjà ça
permettrait d'éviter de polluer
notamment l'ensemble des réseaux sociaux
sur sur ces discours qui n'ont pas leur
place bien évidemment ni dans une
république et encore moins dans un débat
pour l'élection présidentielle d'accord
avec ça alexandre trouver il faut
renforcer l'arsenal législatif
écoutez moi je pense qu'il ya des textes
qui existent en france la personne qui
est visé par
contradicteurs a été condamnée donc le
système juridique fonctionne moi je suis
particulièrement inquiet c'est ici on va
se rapprocher ces questions ce nouvel
antisémitisme la question de la
situation des juifs par exemple dans les
écoles publiques aujourd'hui c'est
extrêmement complexe quand vous êtes un
enfant juif d'être scolarisés dans
certaines villes
donc je pense qu'il faut aussi
aulas jaillir de polémiste qui sont pas
qu'ils apportent pas de la sérénité au
déballage je suis bien d'accord mais je
crois à s'attaquer aux racines du mal
c'est dire que il y a aujourd'hui dans
certains quartiers les enfants juste ne
pas être scolarisés dans beaucoup de
villes en seine saint denis les enfants
jusqu'au peuple ne peuvent plus être
scolarisés donc je pense que on est sur
un débat
comprend bien les propositions du parti
communiste français mais je pense qu'on
est dans un débat beaucoup plus large en
france on a notre sémitisme
structurelles et qui s'installe je le
répète quand un enfant aux justes de
plus été scolarisée dans certaines
quartiers dans certaines villes en
france il faut ouvrir les yeux et notre
société a quand même beaucoup de mal à
ouvrir les yeux sur ce sujet le sénat a
adopté début octobre
résolutions non contraignantes pour
lutter contre toutes les formes
d'antisémitisme
il s'agit avant tout d'adopter une
nouvelle définition parce que on ne
combat bien seulement ce que l'on nomme
bien a fait valoir bruno retailleau
regardé
hier
l'antisémitisme était principalement le
fait une idéologie de l'extrême droite
aujourd'hui un autre écosystème s'est
mise en place dans les territoires
perdus de la république gagné par
l'islamisme des territoires où on ne
peut plus enseigner à l'école la shoah
dans ces territoires combien de familles
ont dû s'exiler la peur au ventre c'est
un antisémitisme qui se cache dans
l'ombre de discours prétendument anti
racistes à l'antisémitisme
caché dans l'ombre de discours
prétendument anti racistes les ondes et
fontanès qu'il ya un double discours
aussi chez certaines personnes
antiracistes et notamment dans les
partis d'extrême gauche
non non non je ne pense pas qu'on puisse
déjà se catégoriser à gauche tout en
ayant des propos antisémites moi je
pense que sur ça on a toujours été clair
ensuite contre vis-à-vis des propos qu'a
tenus monsieur retailleau
aujourd'hui dans les écoles et fort
heureusement notamment par le dévouement
de certains enseignants dans deux hommes
dans l'ensemble des écoles publiques de
france la shoah reste au programme est
enseignée et je pense que et c'est bien
sûr cet angle là qu'il faut privilégier
l'action politique aussi c'est que
l'école est le ciment de toute
république de l'égalité républicaine est
le ciment de toute république elle-même
et l'éducation nationale et je pense
qu'il faut pouvoir justement en effet
remettre de la république partout en
france et notamment à travers le
renforcement du rôle de l'éducation
nationale partout sur le territoire et
moi je ne peux que saluer l'ensemble des
enseignants qui est justement lutte
contre l'obscurantisme
d'où qu'ils viennent qu'ils viennent de
l'extrême droite du communautarisme et
je salue le dévouement de leurs
enseignants mais aujourd'hui
malheureusement des fois ils ne doivent
pas mener à bien leur mission parce que
justement ils n'ont pas les moyens pour
le faire et il ya quand même un enjeu de
moyens qu'on ne peut pas permettre
d'écouter spécifiquement pour pouvoir
enseigner sereinement vous et la shoah
est enseignée dans toutes les écoles
c'est pas forcément le cas quels moyens
faudrait-il mettre à leur disposition
pour pouvoir le faire sereinement
à écouter aujourd'hui la shoah et est au
programme jeux n'a pas relevé par
l'instant d'endroits où il ne l'était
pas ou ne figurait pas dans les
programmes donc je pense que c'est
important que ça irait ce maintenant il
faut pouvoir aussi permettre d'avoir des
conditions de travail pour les
enseignants idéal pour permettre
justement de t'avoir un suivi individuel
de chaque élève alexandre est un manceau
saison pardon à l'ex honteuse et est-ce
que la shoah est enseignée selon vous
dans tous les programmes d'une manière
ou d'une autre et cet antisémitisme
dénoncé par par bruno retailleau et
signé à la haine d'israël
alors je pense qu'il ya quand même une
certaine naïveté dans ce qui vient
d'être exprimée je pense que on a eu un
hommage à sa mère pattie à quelques
jours on a vu les sondages qui a été
extrêmement explicite ou la peur des
enseignants de parler de ce sujet était
extrêmement explicite notamment des
professeurs d'histoire géographie
on sait bien qu'en classe il ya une
concurrence victimaire qui s'exprime et
qu'à chaque fois qu'on parle de la shoah
où nous y posent les
autres concurrence victimaire c'est
extrêmement compliqué voilà non mais
c'est extrêmement compliqué de parler de
ce sujet là en classe il faut vraiment
ouvrir les yeux
l'éducation nationale n'est pas très
très franche sur le sujet on sait bien
qu'il ya des hommages qui ont été
contrariés qui ne sont pas remonté à
l'éducation nationale
tout ça on est ça sous le tapis et
effectivement bonheur retailleau a
raison de dire que une parti d'extrême
gauche s'est fourvoyé je pense à
manifestation 2019 on a vu des gens
porter l'étoile jaune et manifester à
côté du ccf effectivement il ya une
extrême gauche anti sioniste qui dérape
vers l'antisémitisme
il faut le dire qu'ils haussent aussi
coupable moi je ne fais pas de
hiérarchie entre l'antisémitisme
d'extrême droite et l'antisémitisme rixe
d'extrême-gauche
un antisémitisme entre guillemets ou
plutôt un antisioniste il ya ce qui se
passe en israël
c'est un antisionisme qui dérape
et on voit bien il ya des copinages qui
sont qui sont inacceptables moi je
voudrais revenir parce que rona
l'extrême gauche qui à jaillir le
quotidien et le quotidien c'est l'école
et on voit bien la difficulté d'aborder
ces sujets et je partage l'hommage aux
enseignants qui a été exprimé par mon
collègue de plateau mais il faut le dire
aujourd'hui c'est une mission quasi
impossible dans certains quartiers
d'enseigner la shoah de façon tout à
fait sereine dans de dédier ce qui s'est
passé avec samuel pâti de façon tout à
fait sereine dire que les enseignants
ont peur c'est une réalité il ya des
sondages donc c'est pas qu'une question
de moyens il ya une question de moyens
mais c'est une question de
rétablissement l'autorité c'est si on
pose ce sujet on s'occupe de ce sujet là
est le problème c'est que il y avait une
partie de la classe politique est
unanime pour condamner en
l'antisémitisme d'extrême droite mais
quand c'est un antisémitisme de banlieue
on va dire quand c'est un antisémitisme
qui vient d'amis slam plus radicale il
ya une partie du camp politique qui est
moins à l'aise pour le dénoncer
pour des raisons électoralistes et
j'accuserai pas mon interlocuteur parce
que je trouve que le parti communiste
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus clair une
autre partie de l'extrême gauche je dois
le dire et je soutiens les propos par
exemple du secrétaire général sur la
sécurité sur la laïcité qui sont
nettement différent des propos qui sont
tenus par la france a soumises ou par
les verts on voit bien être la gauche
s'est fracturé sur cette question ou pas
l'exemple où l'on va on va écouter ce
qu'avait dit le leader de la france
insoumis jean luc mélenchon qui a
souvent été accusé d'antisémitisme par
le crif il s'en défend regardez
l'antisémitisme est présent mais
n'exagérez pas le peuple français n'est
pas un peuple raciste quand jean luc
mélenchon minimise d'antisémitisme une
insulte pour tous ceux qui sont la cible
et pour la mémoire des français juifs
tués parce que juif les haines et les
populismes ressortent intacte du
confinement la nécessité de les
combattre aussi
un commentaire léon des fontaines est-ce
qu'on accuse à tort ou à raison parfois
la france insoumise de déraper sur un
certain antisémitisme
non je pense qu'on peut pas dire que la
france insoumise dérape sur des propos
antisémites
loin de là je pense qu'au contraire
c'est quand même des forces
progressistes et ne vienne en aucun cas
minimiser minimiser la hausse des actes
antisémites et pour en avoir déjà
discuté avec certains militants la
france insoumise ils ont trait au clair
là dessus ils ont un certain nombre de
revendications je me ferai pas le
défenseur de leurs propos mais je pense
qu'on ne peut pas non plus dire que ils
sont
aussi responsables de hausse des actes
antisémites et je pense pas qu'il ait
qui non plus qu'il ait dit la minimise
loin de là je pense que je sais ça
serait dangereux de dire que ce serait
le cas je pense qu'il veut et pourtant
ils sont tactiles sont systématiquement
attaqués par le crif
enfin c'est leur rôle et d'autres forces
politiques d'autres personnalités
politiques sont également attaquées par
le crif et maintenant il faut regarder
il faut que la justice fasse son travail
je pense que comme l'a rappelé mon monde
et batteur il y a aussi tout un outil
juridique des outils juridiques existent
notamment la loi gayssot qui avait été
mise en place redonner à 90 par un
communiste et je pense qu'elle peut être
saisi à chaque fois qu'il ya une sortie
qu'on juge justement xénophobe raciste
ou antisémite
et
il ya un poste également signé jean yves
le nerf qui a été publié sur la page
facebook de son épouse marthe à
l'honneur ce elle était candidate du
rassemblement national au départementale
sur le canton de bordeaux elle a
vivement fait réagir et entraîner des
sanctions regardez
c'est comme quand tu sert la main d'un
juif tu as intérêt à voir si tu as
encore teddy doit en accord avec la
direction nationale il a été décidé de
retirer le soutien à cette candidate est
de la suspendre le parti réitère sa
condamnation la plus ferme de
l'antisémitisme qui n'a pas sa place
dans ses rangs alors il y a aussi cet
anti son appareil dur de l'antisémitisme
musulman de l'antisémitisme d'extrême
gauche il ya aussi cet antisémitisme
d'extrême droite qui qui qu'ils
continuent en sueur sur les réseaux
sociaux etc cendres touzet condamnée par
le rassemblement national aujourd'hui
est ce que le parti a à tourner la page
en plus qu'à deux de ses de cet
antisémitisme
qui dure maintenant depuis de nombreuses
années
et un habillage politique
effectivement la fille semble vouloir se
distinguer du père après quand vous
voyez dans les composantes dans les
inspirations de ce parti politique dans
l'entente dans sa trajectoire
on peut pas dire qu'il soit totalement
neutre sur le sujet voilà et moi je
franchement je pense qu'il faut mettre
au même niveau les deux antisémitisme et
surtout pas les archives et donc moi je
les combats de façon égalitaire et je
vais dire même si une opération un peu
greenwashing pour dire voilà on sort d
expression du père sur le point de
détail etc il n'empêche que la
composante la trajectoire l'idéologie me
semble être toujours là même si le parti
tente de le voir de les mettre à la
porte
mais ils sont déjà là ce qui veut dire
c'est que c'est extrêmement compliqué
parce que l'on en fait il ya des racines
voilà et
il est rare que vous ayez des sorties de
ce type dans les partis qui ont une
histoire une démarche que plus
républicaine voilà donc oui je pense
qu'à une tentative après voilà il ya des
racines historiques il y a
il y a une culture il y à des groupes
aussi qui sont affiliés au rassemblement
à celles qui sont moi j'étais
représentable qui sont laissés de côté
mais qui sont plus ou moins admis comme
des structures
amis donc je ne pense pas que le
rassembler cela déchets de deuil de
cette pensée nauséabonde alors que le
phénomène on l'a dit a augmenté pendant
la crise sanitaire l'union européenne a
présenté pour la première fois une
stratégie de lutte contre
l'antisémitisme ces derniers jours pour
contrer la haine antisémite en ligne la
commission va soutenir la mise en place
d'un réseau européen d'experts et de
personnes qui vont vérifier les
informations un client y compris des
organisations juives afin de d'accroître
leurs traites des contenus illégaux
regardez ce qu'on a dit le
vice-président de cette commission
justement
nous avons vu pendant la pandémie et les
confinements successifs une résurgence
de vieux mythe conspirationnistes et une
explosion des contenus antisémites en
ligne l'antisémitisme continue à être
non seulement un fardeau du passé mais
aussi une terrible menace dans l'europe
d'aujourd'hui une menace pour l'europe
d'aujourd'hui les ondes et fontanès
qu'il faut combattre cet antisémitisme
au niveau européen est ce que ça vous
semble être possible
ah bah il faut le combattre partout
c'est possible en effet la france n'est
pas la seule à être touchée par une
recrudescence des actes antisémites et
donc oui bien évidemment si on peut le
mener à l'échelle européenne à l'échelle
régionale menon le à l'échelle régionale
moi je pense que il faut lutter contre
toute forme d'obscurs d'obscurantisme
d'antisémitisme et pour cela tous les
outils nécessaires pour le faire sont
sont les bienvenus et donc oui en effet
ces mythes deux mois avant le premier
confinement ont été multipliées par sept
en france 13 en allemagne alexandre
touzet c'est un problème bien plus vaste
un problème français
oui mais en même temps on a quand même
eu depuis le lit les territoires perdus
de la république de 2002 un certain
aveuglement tiers que je vous dise pas
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est une chose
moi j'en reviens au fait est-ce qu'on
peut être juif et de scolariser dans
toutes les écoles publiques en france et
aujourd'hui la réponse est non donc je
pense qu'il faut quand même
revenir sur sur l'essentiel c'est
effectivement extrêmement graves il faut
avoir des outils juridiques pour lutter
contre les propos sur les réseaux
sociaux
aujourd'hui le panne majeure c'est
comment on peut être juif est scolarisé
dans toutes les écoles publiques de
france comment on peut s'appeler milla
et scolarisés normalement dans une école
publique en france
voilà c'est ça me paraît que le problème
majeur il faut se poser des questions il
faut y répondre a été de c'est la tête
sous la couette en disant que le sujet
n'existe pas commencer par l'éducation
on a compris merci à tous les deux merci
beaucoup d'avoir participé à ce débat
sur l'antisémitisme ce matin en direct
sur notre antenne